ما تزال الاحياء القديمه في مدينه قعطبه
بمحافظه الضالع جنوبي اليمن تحافظ على
طابعها المعماري القديم فالمباني الطينيه
تعد النمط السائد فيها ورغم مرور مئات
السنين على بناء بعضها فان معظمها لا يزال
شامخا بينما تهدمت بعض المباني كالبوابه
الرئيسيه للمدينه والسور الطيني الذي كان
يحيط بها مميزات مدينه قعطبه هي سورها
القديم
ومدرستها المسماه بالاحمديه القديمه ايضا
وجامعها الكبير كل هذه مثلا الابنيه قد
ازيلت يفضل معظم سكان المنطقه العيش في
المباني الطينيه القديمه ويرفضون الانتقال
الى المباني الحديثه لكونها تحافظ على
جوها المعتدل على مدار العام
ويقولون انها تذكرهم بابائهم واجدادهم
الذين توارث العيش فيها على مدى سنوات
طويله فضلنا هذه البيوت السكن في هذه
البيوت لانها بيوت حضاريه وثقافيه
وسكن فيها الاباء والاجداد وهي بيوت
فيها سكن مريع يعني ممتاز في الصيف في
الشتاء ما نشعرش الا في الدفن ما نشعر
بالبروده القاسيه ولا بالحمااء الزايد
يقدر عدد المباني الطينيه في مدينه قعطبه
بنحو 150 يحتاج 50 منها على الاقل الى
ترميم ويعود بناء بعض تلك المباني الى ما
قبل 300 عام
مدينه قعطبه تتميز بالفن المعماري القديم
والجمال المعماري الطيني الذي يحمل دلالات
عميقه بالمعنى والقيمه
ولها معالم اثريه
يحاول الاهالي الحفاظ على المباني الطينيه
القديمه من خلال ترميمها كل عام بما يتوفر
لهم من امكانيه وسط مطالبات للجهات
المختصه في الحكومه اليمنيه والمنظمات
الدوليه بالقيام بدورها في الحفاظ على تلك
المباني